natation course à pied ou la route
laisse la place aux forêts et aux
chemins et les vélos profil et au vtt
vous êtes au premier championnat de
france de cross triathlon il faut faire
attention aux coups de pompe après le
passage à vélo en vtt on ne peut pas se
cacher dans l'hérault comme les coureurs
peuvent le faire sur route derrière la
course devient vite casse pattes comme
on dit dans le peloton
comparé aux types de triathlon que j'ai
fait coupe d'europe ou grand prix élite
c'est un peu plus dur parce que là on
est en vérité on est toujours en prise
sa demande de toujours toujours relancer
toujours pédaler musculairement on se
repose jamais en vtt 1 quasiment jamais
et ensuite quand on enchaîne sur du
travail de chemin du chemin ou de
l'herbe
là faut quand même faut quand même des
cuisses comparer
du tout plat sur la route c'est vrai que
c'est quand même plusieurs le vtt
justement le champion de france brice
daubord l'a mal encaissée sorti en tête
de l'eau ils posent le vélo avec une
minute de retard sur le monégasque
nicolas fernandez mais au prix d'une
remontée à pied phénoménal le médaillé
de bronze au championnat d'europe 2012
s'impose finalement en 1h31
chez les vétérans le versailles et
olivier constantin a conquis ce premier
titre historique
je suis très très content de mac ans et
c'était je voulais faire le trou en
natation parce que je savais qu'avec des
vétérans très costaud en had vélo j'ai
tout donné dans le premier tour à vélo
pour me mettre à l'abri et après j'ai
essayé de gérer en course à pied et je
suis très très satisfait grâce à leur
performance d'ensemble les versaillais
remporte le titre par équipes
et évidemment pour un triathlon du roi
le nouveau champion prend place sur son
trône une couronne pour l'histoire du
triathlon français